the search operation is continuing but
the weather is turning and storms are
forecast
the ship that brought the dead ashore is
back in Port and the survivors are being
looked after in a nearby Warehouse
all of them so far are men aged between
15 and 45.
no one is sure exactly how many people
are on board
everyone knows though it was a lot these
people said that about
7.75
700 and 75 years but uh I think is
is about this small for this number I
think it's a 500 uh
in this bottle 550.
some of the survivors are being treated
in a local hospital and there is now
confirmation that women and children
were on board
all the women are dead says this
Survivor the women and children are dead
because they were sleeping in one room
they were staying in the room so it's
impossible that they didn't drown
relatives of the missing have come to
Greece to try and find their loved ones
aftab Khan is from the UK his cousins
were traveling from Pakistan you're
searching for your relatives
how many roses are you missing there's
three rotors and we found one relatively
and
um I don't know how they're connected to
you
um
cousins there are questions why the
Greek Coast Guard didn't intervene when
they first realized that the boat was
carrying migrants and dangerously
overcrowded they say that the boat was
in international waters and that they
were operating to International laws
it's getting close to 48 hours since the
Shipwreck and no new survivors have been
found add to that the fact that it
capsized and sank in one of the deepest
parts of the Mediterranean Sea and we
might never know how many people lost
their lives on Tuesday night
nevertheless the search goes on and
Greece is in a three-day period of
national mourning for the victims
for all the calls to prevent a repeat
disaster there will be more this summer
almost certainly
Alistair bunker Sky News in Kalamata in
southern Greece